it's interesting cuz I a couple of years
ago I love Tarantino's movies and I know
that you've been uh in a couple and um
you did once upon a time in LA yeah and
um playing this stunt coordinator and
what's interesting is I read this
interview with Tarantino where he said
Kurt's one of the only guys I can talk
to who because he he's making a movie
about La in
6869 Kurt knew all these people you
experienced that world and he said you
informed so much of like he picked your
brain about what was La like back then
because you started out doing you know
Disney films early on yeah and tele did
a lot of Television early yeah just
working you know working actors my my
brother Neo as a TV head and I swear to
God I wake up this morning he's like ask
him about being un Lost in
Space and I'm like
no you should because it's a good one
for your world my character's name was
guano yeah you know what but they
finally figured out after the show like
you know what guano means yeah bad
to play Michael onar as kid I that
was it was one of the first experiences
I ever had where I was kind of like I
know what I want to do here and I
because he Michael lar was bald yeah and
we were you know was lost in space
you're not on Earth you're somewhere out
there and uh I went oh great I I know
what I want to do and I I don't know how
I don't remember how I convinced it I
said I want to I want to be bald too
right so I got to be I got to play a
character that was you know looked I
looked like that we were clearly not
from pea you know from a different
planet but but bigpaw bigpaw knew all
those wasn't a lot of that based on your
dad had worked uh in early what in in
film but had he done television as well
no my dad my dad you know worked for a
long time he put you know shoes on his
kids feet and food on the table by being
an actor and he did everything it worked
for a long time um but he was what you
know we kind of looked at each other as
plumber actors you know I mean there
like take your work pale and go to work
you know but with with quen we talked a
lot about stuff he he's very he loves he
loves the history of Hollywood and he he
probably knows it as well as anybody and
so he does it's more than picking your
brain it's for you're going to go out
and have a good time and and he used a
lot of uh uh the conversation I think
the things that he has learned over the
years from many different people and it
was it was very nice that he made a a
dedication in in the book that he wrote
um about Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
and he did have me come over to his
house to read it and it was really
interesting because I think he wanted me
to read it in the lair you know and it
was right in the heart he loves living
where he lives in the heart of Hollywood
as it were and uh you know it was a
great feeling and I I must say I said to
him I said I don't know if there's
anybody alive who can appreciate this as
much as me because it was my it was like
your my life you know it was like
completely I I understand everything
about it you know I have a fascination
with that era so there's a clip you can
see online I guess someone in like 1966
just drove along some at Boulevard now
today everyone has a
phone but back then it was very rare for
people to you know have a a color film
camera and someone just shot out their
windshield driving along the Sunset
Strip in 1966 and I'm and and it's a
different world and I've looked at that
thing so many times I love time travel
and that's just an amazing you look at
that LA and we don't live in that La
anymore it's it's gone but it's so
strange and so different
I I love watch I love watching those
videos it is a sense of nostalgia that
you're like oh wow and living back in
that time I'm sure you go back in that
time and you're like this is a
nightmare get me back into
2023 but I love I yeah I I know those
ones where you kind of like they put it
on the hood of a car and they just kind
of drift through Los Ang yeah they drive
through LA and you see what the cars
look like how the people dressed what
it's strange it is strange to me to live
long enough to see that there really is
a difference as time goes by because it
always kind of feels the same to me you
know
but you're why I was telling me G this
is cool because we have something fun
for you but you're a you're a pretty
serious history buff yes you like love I
love reading history yeah I got to got
he
said be totally false no I don't think
it is though I don't think it is no I
think this one's pretty bar so um uh
there was a time where I wasn't working
very much and um I subscribed to
ancestry.com um like like a 75y old
grandmother yeah uh and so I got
obsessed with uh like following the
history of our family it was like oh you
know our history of family is cool and
so you go back a couple Generations
keeps going back and it gives you these
like heat Leaf hints right yeah this is
also I'm getting paid by ancestry.com
right
now and I enjoy driving a
Porsche never
works um and and so it just kept going
back and kept going back and it was like
to the gaken backs and all these
different people that we were and then
it and then it always shows uh war
records right like that it traces your
family history through war
records turn went goes all the way back
to the Revolutionary War and everybody
in our family for whatever reason has
fought in a war this is the Russell side
the Russell side of the family uh and
and um we get to 10 Generations back
from me his name is Jason Russell
Jr on the first day of the Revolutionary
War
uh shot her around the world at lexingon
conquered y when the Minutemen retreated
there was a house and they took refuge
in the house they sheltered in in the
house the red Coates surrounded the
house went in shot everybody in the
house baded the owner of the house 11
times and it turns out that the owner of
that house was Jason Russell Jr who is
our direct lineage great-grandfather
insane on that day it was the bloodiest
day of fighting on the first day of
retion house if only it had a ring
camera ding
dong hello you want to come in nobody
here well well the joke is I was the
joke is is like that you know the it's
this patriotic story and he got banded
at his door and the story is he came
back his family sent his family away and
he came back and you know the Red Coats
came in and they stabbed him and I was
like well how do you know wasn't going
to the door and being like they're in
here they in there no not me I love the
king yeah
exactly uh Lisa kudro has a lineage show
and she approached me a number of years
ago and she said uh you I we want to we
find prominent people and we do their
lineage and uh she and I have been
friends for a long time and then she
said would you take a swab and we'll
find your lineage and I said I promise
you you're not going to find anything
and he said Conan everyone says that but
we we always find no you're related to
you know Winston church or you're
related to it's so cool you're going to
see and I said you'll see didn't hear
from her for 6 months and then I call
her and I go Lisa I never heard back
from you when she went there's
[Laughter]
nothing